concerned that you about the report into
the fire service and will you reform it
as I said there's been reports
previously about emergency services and
most notably the Casey report recently
into what's been going on in the police
I said at the time what I read about
them what we all read about was
appalling to see that abuse of power
it's right that the Metropolitan Police
in particular take the steps required to
reform the police services to make sure
that people have confidence in them and
it also I want to make sure that people
know we're clamping down on crime
earlier this week we announced new plans
to clamp down on anti-social Behavior
Banning nitrous oxide making sure that
people face immediate Justice for the
littering graffiti they're doing in
their communities I know that's
something that's incredibly important to
people here in TSI our local councilors
are delivering that as well we're
clamping down on anti-social Behavior
thanks very much indeed